und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend manchmal passen klischees ja doch
die neue corona app wurde mit deutscher
gründlichkeit erstellt durch diskutiert
und geprüft so dass man sich eigentlich
auch nicht wundert dass ihre einführung
zwei monate länger dauerte als
ursprünglich angekündigt dafür soll sie
jetzt nach den worten des
kanzleramtsministers aber auch die beste
corona app der welt sein darunter machen
es nicht
der bevölkerung wird also nicht
irgendeine karre angeboten sondern ein
mercedes der s-klasse vor die tür
gestellt
selbst die hacker vom chaos computer
club die sonst eigentlich immer was zu
meckern haben heben die daumen das ding
sei sicher und wirklich kein
überwachungsinstrumente so der
einhellige tenor von experten die große
frage ist nur werden die bürger da auch
einsteigen
sonst war die ganze mühe in der milch
umsonst de shop richtet einen countdown
gibt es nicht auch keinen konfettiregen
aber dass je nach wahrnehmung der
beteiligten großes vollbracht wurde
sieht man an manchem gesicht und hört
man auch was münchen heraus das ist
nicht die erste corona app weltweit die
vorgestellt wird
aber ich bin ziemlich überzeugt es ist
die beste sie herunterzuladen und zu
nutzen das ist ein kleiner schritt für
jeden von uns aber ein großer schritt
für die pandemie bekämpfung kleiner
schritt großer schritt mondlandungs
rhetorik es ist ein später schritt jens
spahn hatte die app für april
angekündigt und muss sich die frage
gefallen lassen was sie noch bringt bei
niedrigeren infektionszahlen wir sind
aktuell stand heute mit den
infektionszahlen in einer guten lage
aber wir wollen uns diese lage ja auch
erhalten das erreichte sichern und dabei
leistet die app einen wichtigen beitrag
gerade in einer phase wo wir jetzt ja
zug um zug in den bundesländern sehen
und entscheiden miteinander dass es mehr
und mehr lockerungen gibt mehr als 1,5
millionen menschen haben die app seit
mitternacht schon heruntergeladen
manche hatten probleme wegen veralteter
betriebssysteme
die datenschutzbedenken die anfangs groß
waren scheint verschwunden
die app soll helfen festzustellen welche
menschen 15 minuten kontakt hatten aber
nicht wo das stattfand und wie die
personen heißt sie ist die antwort
deutschlands oder europas gegen eine
asiatische art der app die nämlich nicht
auf datenschutz wert legt bei uns wird
auf datenschutz auf freiwilligkeit und
auf pseudo novität wert gelegt es ist
gut dass jetzt da ist und doch fürchten
manche dass die app nicht so freiwillig
ist wie sie sein soll
wenn sie zum beispiel verlangt wird als
eintrittskarte im restaurant oder im
kino oder gar pflicht wird am
arbeitsplatz die app kann nur
erfolgreich sein wenn sie großes
vertrauen genießt und große akzeptanz
hat das wird nicht funktionieren wenn
die freiwilligkeit in der
lebenswirklichkeit unterwandert wird
wenn zum beispiel wie es jetzt schon
offensichtlich passiert arbeitgeber zu
ihren angestellten gehen und verlangen
dass diese app installiert wird
das ist dann eine nötigung durch die
hintertür und das muss gesetzlich
verhindert werden
die bundesregierung will ein solches
gesetz nicht setzt auf das prinzip
freiwilligkeit und hofft dass er schon
gut geht dass aufgrund der
ausdrücklichen freiwilligkeit und der
anderen möglichkeiten die ich als
arbeitgeber ja auch habe
infektionsschutz im unternehmen zu
gewährleisten
überwiegt hier ausdrücklich diese
freiwilligkeit und auch hier fährt die
app ihrer grenze im ausland funktioniert
das deutsche system nicht und noch gibt
es keine europäische kooperation
es gibt ja einige länder da sind auch
viele deutsche gleichzeitig im urlaub da
macht es dann schon ein unterschied und
viele sind in deutschland im urlaub und
es macht einen unterschied für die
rückkehr aus dem urlaub auch das haben
wir in den letzten monaten erlebt die
app ist am start aber alle wissen dass
sie nur hilft wenn sie auch von vielen
bedient wird herunterladen reicht dann
nicht über corona und die app wollen wir
mit helge braun chef sprechen dem chef
des bundeskanzleramts frau merkels
wichtigsten mann in dieser pandemie
guten abend herr braun
einen schönen guten abend russland als
manche zuschauer vielleicht nicht wissen
ist dass sie sind von haus aus mediziner
haben auch bis 2007 an einer uniklinik
als arzt gearbeitet nun beugen sie sich
quasi bei den patient deutschland in
dieser pandemie
bevor über die app reden wie besorgt
sind sie im blick auf die urlaubszeit
jetzt dann wieder sehr viel gereist und
auch ins ausland gefahren wird die
tatsache dass die wir die app haben das
hilft dann natürlich auch bei wir haben
ja am anfang der krise auch gesehen dass
zb reiserückkehrer aus einem hotspot
nämlich ischgl sich dann in ganz
deutschland verteilen und das kann
natürlich schon dazu führen dass wir
nicht so ein lokales ausbruchsgeschehen
haben wir über das momentan häufig sehen
sondern dass es dann eher wieder viele
vereinzelte fälle gibt und das müssen
wir natürlich dann auch schnell erkennen
und darauf reagieren hat die app den
kleinen schönheitsfehler dass im ausland
ja nicht funktioniert also wenn mir ein
franzose mit seinem handy in frankreich
begegnete er sich später als co wird 19
positiv heraus stellt trifft mir das
jetzt dann nichts an dem fall
also wir arbeiten unter hochdruck dran
im augenblick ist es ist es richtig nur
wenn sich zwei menschen begegnen die
beide die deutsche app auf ihrem handy
haben dann wird der kontakt entsprechend
festgestellt aber insbesondere im süden
also österreich schweiz italien
wir haben auch eine app die so dezentral
arbeitet wie unsere da glauben wir dass
wir sehr schnell es schaffen dass die
zusammenarbeiten und diejenigen den
zentralen ansatz haben also wo auch
daten an den staat weiter gegeben werden
wie zum beispiel in frankreich das
streben wir das auch an
aber das ist technisch deutlich
schwieriger weil wir natürlich unser
hohes datenschutzniveau dadurch nicht
beeinträchtigen wollen nun kroos geht
das vielleicht doch eher etwas später
die große frage wird zahlen wie viele
deutsche sich diese app runterladen
experten sagen dass müssten eigentlich
schon 60 prozent der bevölkerung seien
damit es wirklich etwas prägt das ist so
eine aussage die entstammt dieser oxford
studie
da hat man gesagt 60 prozent wenn wir
sonst nichts machen wenn das sozusagen
das zentrale instrument zur bekämpfung
der pandemie es bei uns ist es ja so
dass abstand halten was getragen und
auch die normale kontakt nach verfolgung
durch den gesundheitsdienst bleiben ja
und deshalb gehen wir davon aus es gibt
keine mindestschwelle ab wann
hilft wenn sozusagen einer früher
erfährt dass er sich infiziert hat
dadurch dass wir die app haben dann ist
es schon ein wert und je mehr das nutzen
desto mehr hilft sie auch besonders
wichtig ist dass sie halt die leute
benutzen die häufig auch mit menschen in
kontakt kommen die sie nicht kennen also
ganz klassisch im bus und bahn wo einer
neben einem sitzt im money informieren
könnte weil man ihnen gar nicht
persönlich kennt und da ist ja auch die
idee aufkommen dass zum beispiel kino
sagen oder restaurants sagen nur noch
leute die diese app geladen haben die
lassen wir uns rein weil wir eigentlich
auch keine lust mehr haben ständig
adressen von gästen aufzuschreiben und
das sparen wir uns dann anders gekommen
das dürfen die nicht aktiv die pflicht
die teilnehmer selber auch zu schreiben
bleibt erhalten das kann man nicht durch
die app ersetzen und es ergibt auch gar
keinen sinn weil die app ist nur eine
information für mich sie ist völlig
freiwillig und sie gibt mir ein risiko
auch nur dann richtig wieder
wenn ich sie effektiv benutze ich könnte
sie auch zum beispiel den ganzen tag zu
hause liegen lassen
dann zeigt sie ein geringes risiko an
hat aber mit dem was ich am tag getan
habe gar nichts zu tun und deshalb die
klare aussage der bundesregierung wir
möchten nicht dass irgendjemand die app
als zugangsbedingungen oder in anderer
weise nutzt sie solle freiwillig sein es
soll jeder einzelne selber entscheiden
ob er sie benutzen möchte sagt dagegen
entscheidet finden wir das schade aber
das darf keine nach drei für ihn sein
könnte man dann diese glasklare aussage
die sie sagen dann nicht auch in ein
glasklares gesetz gießen warum kommt das
nicht so festgelegt wird nein das ist
verboten zu sagen im restaurant zum
beispiel darfst du moment app und wo
auch diese freiwilligkeit festgelegt
wird also wir wollen das in die
allgemeinen geschäftsbedingungen der app
noch mal rein schreiben
um das noch einmal deutlich zu
unterstreichen aber da ich eben gesagt
habe es ergibt auch gar keinen sinn
glauben wir dass es verzichtbar ist dass
man jetzt noch eine solche app
eingesetzt
da hat niemand was davon wenn er
versucht was darauf verpflichtend zu
machen
sie ist freiwillig und sie soll auch
freiwillig bleiben und das ist die klare
politische aussage der bundesregierung
deshalb ist ein gesetz das haben wir
heute auch noch mal so deutlich gemacht
aus unserer sicht nicht erforderlich
sagte kanzleramtsminister
er braucht nicht danke für das gespräch
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt wenn sie sich die app noch mal
im einzelnen erklären lassen wollen
wie man sie installiert wie sie
funktioniert dann finden sie dazu jede
menge informationen und videos auf zdf
heute in den letzten zwölf monaten waren
nicht zu übersehen welche gefahr von
rechtsextremisten hierzulande aus geht
nicht dass man das nicht schon seit
jahrzehnten wissen könnte gewalt von
rechts gab es immer wieder reichlich und
spätestens die morde des nsu hätten
genug aufrütteln müssen nun haben die
anschläge von halle und hanau und der
tod des cdu politikers walter lübke das
erneut ins öffentliche bewusstsein
gebracht
alle diese anschläge sollten nicht nur
die jeweiligen opfer töten und ihre
angehörigen quellen sondern weit darüber
hinaus angst und schrecken verbreiten
wenn eine shisha bar sitzt soll sich
nicht sicher fühlen
wer in einer synagoge betet soll sich
nicht sicher fühlen und angst haben soll
auch wer politische verantwortung trägt
so wie walter lippe ist hat in seiner
mordfall hat heute der gerichtsprozess
begonnen christian decker berichtet zehn
minuten vor verhandlungsbeginn betritt
die familie von walter lübke heute
vormittag den gerichtssaal begleitet von
ihrem anwalt
sie wolle ein klares signal setzen so
ein sprecher der familie ein signal der
verbundenheit zu ihrem vater und man und
insbesondere zu seinen werten bei der
preisverleihung an walter lübke posthum
hatte seinen sohn im dezember gesagt
hast brutalität froh demokratie
verachtung und die absetzung des anderen
werden zunehmend salonfähig sogar vor
einem feigen und hinterhältigen mord
schreckten die extremisten nicht zurück
im sinne unseres vaters ist es unser
aller auftrag diesem schrecklichen
ungeist entgegenzuwirken
als der mutmaßliche mörder stefan ernst
heute in den gerichtssaal geführt wird
stellen sich die witwe und die beiden
söhne dieser begegnung aufrecht die
bundesanwaltschaft wirft ihm mord vor
der zweite angeklagte markus h soll ihm
beihilfe
mord geleistet haben die verteidiger
stellen heute am ersten verhandlungstag
verschiedene anträge darunter einen auf
befangenheit gegen den vorsitzenden
richter über die anträge muss noch
entschieden werden
im bürgerhaus lohfelden filmte markus h
2015 jene szene mit dem handy die aus
walter lübke eine hassfigur der rechten
szene machte lübke sprach über die
flüchtlingspolitik der bundesregierung
anschließend berufe auch von den beiden
angeklagten unser vater war ein mann des
klaren wortes freiheitliche
überzeugungen und demokratischer werte
seinen standpunkt konnte er mit
nachdruck charmant und auch mit ironie
vertreten
zum prozessauftakt in frankfurt ist das
interesse sehr groß mehr als 200
journalisten hatten sich akkreditiert
darunter auch rob savelberg von der
größten niederländischen zeitung de
telegraaf
er ist extra angereist ein rechter
politiker der wurde ermordet
den vorteilen in 2002 und das hat das
land sehr nachhaltig verändert also das
land es gibt das land vor dem mord und
das land nach dem mord in deutschland
weiß ich nicht was das bedeutet der
prozess ist in deutschland sicherlich
ein wichtiger teil der aufarbeitung und
walter lüpkes haltung seine werte waren
auch heute präsent und zwar direkt über
dem eingang für alle sichtbar
rechtsextremismus und rassismus gehen
hand in hand
aber rassistische einstellungen gibt es
ja beileibe nicht nur bei extremisten
das geht viel tiefer in die gesellschaft
hinein und dafür muss man auch nicht in
die usa blicken bittere rassismus
erfahrungen machen viele menschen auch
hierzulande jeden tag wird man ihnen zu
kann man manchmal kaum fassen was sie da
so alles erleben müssen wie viel
boshaftigkeit es gibt aber auch wie viel
dummheit und manchmal auch einfach nur
gedankenlosigkeit war nicht böse gemeint
aber trotzdem
heute hat bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier zugehört er lud vier gäste
nach schloss bellevue ein
für deutsche die erzählen was sie in
deutschland erleben
ich wurde bespuckt ich wurde
zusammengeschlagen auch in der schule
man redet über rassismus aber nie mit
den leuten die diese auch wirklich
erfahren haben unsere erfahrung ist es
tatsächlich die auch in der studie der
antidiskriminierungsstelle bestätigt
wird dass rassistische diskriminierung
über zeit zugenommen hat in der straße
kann wenn jetzt eine alte dame
dies sieht auch weil ihre tasche weg
nimmt totti denkt juni klaus
unternehmens die tasche weg lassen also
erfahrungen die du bekommen wo gesagt
was das kann ja was passiert sie aber
das typische alltagsrassismus und wir
können nicht den tod von george floyd
beklagen und rassismus wo es ihn gibt im
eigenen land verschweigen
wenn der begriff geändert werden wird
dann nur wenn sichergestellt ist dass
das schutzniveau gleich ist oder höher
wird was dafür spricht natürlich dass es
in deutschland und auf der ganzen welt
keine biologischen rassen gibt war was
ist denn rasse was ich meine ich hab das
ich habe das so dass wir alle wir sind
alle gleich und wenn sowas in ein
grundgesetz besteht das ist ja schon
riesenfeier sondern wie wir kennen wir
auch dass wir als nation werden wollen
wir wollen die stimmung erleben denn es
gibt ja keine rassen ja wenn das wort im
grundgesetz auftaucht suggeriert es gäbe
die verschiedene kategorien von rassen
die gibt es nicht der mensch ist eine
einzige rasse reicht mich aus kein
rassist zu sein
wir müssen antirassisten sagen müssen
das thematisieren dass menschen wirklich
auch in den schulen rassistisch
behandelt werden und müssen es quasi
wirklich auch auf die auf die agenda des
unterrichts setzen
ich glaube das problem ist dass die
meisten leute gar nicht wissen dass
rassismus keine meinung ist sondern eine
straftat und das wenn man nicht wenn man
sich nicht bewusst ist es eine straftat
es dann immer einerseits ganz normal war
und dann wird es einfach weitergegeben
und wenn wir immer noch begriffe die
rassistisch sind reproduzieren im
öffentlichen raum du musst auch
angegangen werden und straßen müssen auf
jeden fall umbenannt werden wir müssen
uns unsere sprache angucken mit dem wort
schwach es ist so viel verbunden was nur
negativ ist wir sagen die ganze zeit
jemand arbeitet schwarz ich fahre
schwarz damit suggerieren wir den
menschen ja etwas damit wachsen kleine
kinder auf die lernen das motto schwarz
ist etwas böses antirassismus muss
gelernt wie übt vor allen dingen aber
gelebt
ein bericht von patricia wiedemeier war
das und jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf
weiter mit anderen nachrichten in den
beziehungen zwischen nord- und südkorea
gibt es erneut einen deutlichen
rückschlag
offenbar als reaktion auf
flugblattaktionen südkoreanischer
aktivisten hat nordkorea das erste
gemeinsame verbindungsbüro nahe der
grenze gesprengt
bilder aus südkorea zeigen eine
explosion und eine rauchsäule auf dem
gelände das verbindungsbüro war wegen
der korona schutzmaßnahmen zuletzt nicht
mehr genutzt worden
nordkorea stellte auch die
friedensvereinbarungen der gipfeltreffen
von 2018 infrage und will möglicherweise
wieder soldaten in den dem alle
militarisierten pufferzonen stationieren
spannungen auch zwischen china und
indien an der umstrittenen grenze der
beiden länder kam es zu einer
gewaltsamen auseinandersetzung mit toten
auf beiden seiten berichtet die in die
therme china und indien machen sich
gegenseitig für den vorfall
verantwortlich und werfen der jeweils
anderen seite provokationen vor
inzwischen sollen hochrangige
militärvertreter beider seiten gespräche
aufgenommen haben um die lage in der
region zu entschärfen
die sich in den letzten wochen zunehmend
verschärft hatte in frankreich haben
heute landesweit ärzte und
krankenpfleger gegen die finanznot an
öffentlichen krankenhäusern protestiert
wir in paris gingen insgesamt tausende
auf die straße und forderten eine
bessere bezahlung und mehr mittel für
die versorgung von patienten einige
französische krankenhäuser waren in der
korona krise überlastet besonders im
großraum paris und an der deutsch
französischen grenze
der cdu politiker philipp am tor zieht
sich nach zdf informationen aus dem
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestages
zum terror anschlag auf dem berliner
breitscheidplatz zurück er reagiert
damit offenbar auf lobbyismus vorwürfe
der 27 jährige steht in der kritik weil
er sich bei der bundesregierung für das
us-unternehmen augustus intelligence
eingesetzt hatte von dem im gegenzug
aktienoptionen erhalten hatte
diese habe er inzwischen zurückgegeben
die bundesregierung will mobilfunk
löcher in deutschland schließen und
dafür mehr als eine milliarde euro
ausgeben
das gab verkehrsminister scheuer nach
einem mobilfunk gipfel in berlin bekannt
für das geld fließe in den bau von fünf
maß besonders ländliche gebiete mit
mindestens 4 g empfang zu versorgen
dafür soll eine neue staatliche
mobilfunkinfrastruktur gesellschaft
die schaffen das verhältnis zwischen
polizei und bürgern ist in den usa ein
anderes als in deutschland
wer jemals in den usa in eine
polizeikontrolle geriet weiß wie anders
sich das anfühlt das ist gewissermaßen
der preis den die amerikaner für ihre
freiheit zahlen sich ab teenager-alter
bis unter die zähne bewaffnet zu dürfen
erschütternd ist wie viele amerikaner
bei polizeieinsätzen sterben zum
beispiel bei festnahmen wie bei george j
vergangenes jahr waren es mehr als 1000
1002 menschen
zum vergleich in deutschland gab es 14
personen die durch polizeikugeln starben
hinzu kommt der strukturellen rassismus
der sich in diesen toten zahlen verbirgt
denn für schwarze amerikaner ist das
risiko von polizisten getötet zu werden
dreimal höher als verweise die angst
davor ist in schwarzen familien immer
präsent angesichts der massiven proteste
im land hat donald trump nun eine
polizeireform angekündigt motive sind
berichtet es gibt einen ort in amerika
der ist so anders nette polizisten
freundliche menschen in kärnten new
jersey weil sie hier vor jahren gemacht
haben was demonstranten überall im land
fordern die alte polizei abgeschafft
eine neue aufgebaut basierend auf drei
prinzipien
jeder neue beamte sollte er ein
beschützer seien kein krieger
wir würden versuchen das
gemeinschaftsgefühl zu stärken und
deeskalation sollte der kern unserer
behörde sind wir verlangten von unseren
beamten er teil eines friedens kurs zu
sein statt mitglieder eines
spezialeinsatzkommandos präsident obama
nannte die stadt ein vorbild die neue
polizei zeigte präsenz im öffentlichen
raum gab viele aufgaben an andere helfer
die mordrate 1 die höchste im land sank
um 70 prozent der jetzige polizeichef
marschiert sogar mit den demonstranten
für viele ein modell für das land wenn
sich die beamten neu bewerben müssen auf
neue aufgaben beschreibungen mit einem
völlig neuen verständnis ihrer rolle
solche schritte sind wirklich notwendig
nach nur vier monaten ausbildung greifen
zu viele polizisten in amerika zu
schnell zu gewalt dort stellte keine
gefahr mehr dar richard brooks in
atlanta war nur getrunken
die beamten hätten ihn von seiner
familie abholen lassen können in solchen
fällen ruft die polizei in eugene oregon
auf sozialarbeiter der privaten
initiative kappus herbei
die sich um obdachlose und verwirrte
menschen statt als einzige option
polizei feuerwehr oder notarzt zu
bekommen wenn man den notruf wählt
sollte man auch die hilfe von
psychologen erbitten können oder von
experten die sich mit suchtfragen
auskennen solche initiativen will der
präsident nun fördern er ordnete auch
die schaffung einer nationalen datenbank
für beamte an die mit exzessiver gewalt
die regeln gebrochen haben aber am ende
hängt es ab von menschen wie sheriff
madschid wurde im landkreis wohl user
florida liegt der schwerpunkt der
ausbildung in der entschärfung von
konflikten ohne gleich die waffe zu
ziehen
geleitet von einer einfachen philosophie
es ist genauso gute polizeiarbeit ein
leben zu retten wie einen bösewicht zu
stoppen der mit einer waffe ein massaker
in warschau ist die zahl der festnahmen
um ein drittel gesunken
der einsatz von zwang durch die deputy
sogar um 50 prozent
es ist ein miteinander mit den menschen
hier aber für den rest amerikas ein
weiter weg
angesichts der hoch aufgerüsteten und
meist schlecht ausgebildeten polizei in
den usa
themawechsel außenpolitik macht donald
trump nämlich auch noch unbekannt
robustem stil
gestern wandte er sich ja explizit an
deutschland und erklärte zur strafe
dafür dass die deutschen zu geringe
verteidigungsausgaben hätten werde er
rund 10.000 us soldaten aus deutschland
abziehen
dabei wollen wir mit unserem
korrespondenten in washington und berlin
sprechen mrt sind in washington sowie
der us präsident das formuliert hat man
das ja eigentlich erpressung oder ja das
kann man so nennen man kann es auch
masche nennen die funktioniert ich will
mal ein beispiel denn südkorea südkorea
hat zur truppenpräsenz der usa im land
800 millionen dollar pro jahr
beigetragen
donald trump hätte gerne ein paar
milliarden dollar dafür
die koreanische regierung hatte sich
geweigert und daraufhin wurden dann
einfach die koran koreanischen
zivilangestellten nach hause geschickt
ohne gehalt bis dann die koreanische
regierung eingelenkt hat sie zahlt jetzt
diese gehälter selbst 200 millionen
dollar im jahr mehr
es geht hier ums geschäftemachen aber
auch ein stück weit um den wahlkampf
denn das kommt wunderbar an bei den
anhängern von donald trump im wahlkampf
kann ein stück weit auch von eigenen
fehlern ablenken selbst seine
parteifreunde in der republikanischen
partei gehen davon aus es geht hier um
den kurzfristigen nutzen ohne den
langfristigen schaden zu bedenken denn
deutschland als drehscheibe der
us-soldaten die in den nahen osten oder
nach afrika gehen zu verlieren das würde
amerika großen schaden zufügen meinen
sie jedenfalls
theo koll wie ihre agentin hat in berlin
auf diese neueste ansage des präsidenten
eigentlich eher resigniert kühl nach dem
motto so tickt einfach emotional und
dann geld orientiert wie wir gerade
gehört haben aber die reaktion werden
jetzt doch deutlich schärfer als man das
in richtung des ängsten oder man muss
vielleicht sagen ehemals engsten
verbündeten erwarten würde heute abend
jedenfalls hat die
verteidigungsministerin bei einer rede
gesagt sicherheit sei keine ware und die
nato keine handelsorganisationen und der
spd-fraktionschef meinte der
us-präsident verstehe sich als inkasso
eintreiber weil deutschland nicht
gebührend hohe militärische ausgaben
leisten also diplomatische zurückhaltung
kann man das kaum noch nennen nach
unseren informationen übrigens rechnet
die bundesregierung im laufenden jahr
mit einem deutlich höheren anteil der
verteidigungsausgaben durch den
wirtschaftseinbruch steigt der anteil
der verteidigung am bruttoinlandsprodukt
auf über 1,5 prozent aber die zahl wird
natürlich nicht reichen um das deutsch
amerikanische porzellan in den händen
von sonnenschirm zu kitten dankeschön
nach berlin und nach fasching und jetzt
nochmal heiß mit dem blick auf die
deutsche wirtschaft die inflationsrate
in deutschland ist im mai weiter
gesunken
nur noch um 0,6 prozent lagen die
verbraucherpreise über dem niveau des
vorjahresmonats hat das statistische
bundesamt errechnet und dass frank
bethmann trotz milliardenschwerer
konjunkturunterstützung wie so steigen
die preise da nicht stärker da
eigentlich kennen wir das ja bereits von
der letzten großen krise auf rund zwölf
jahren wurden milliarden in die märkte
gepumpt drastisch gestiegen sind die
preise unter dem strich damals dennoch
nicht zwei wichtige argumente wer angst
um seinen job hat kauft weniger das
drückt auf die preise ebenso wie die
tatsache dass durch das internet preise
heute viel besser vergleichbar sind
preiserhöhungen dadurch schwerer werden
und doch steigen die preise geführt und
zwar mehr als nur die 0,6 prozent binnen
jahresfrist warum das so ist wird klar
wenn man die zuletzt stark gefallenen
energiepreise herausrechnet dann sind
wir bereits bei 1,6 prozent und schaut
man nur auf die sehr häufig gekauften
nahrungsmittel beträgt die teuerung
sogar 4,5 prozent schon lange gibt es
kritik an den statistischen warenkorb
der die inflations berechnung zugrunde
liegt insbesondere jetzt nachdem corona
bedingt mehrere monate
restaurantbesuche oder urlaube gar nicht
möglich waren aber obst gemüse und
fleisch waren im preis nach oben
geschossen sind wie aussagekräftig sind
diese zahlen also noch für die
europäische zentralbank sind sie noch
immer das maß der dinge inflationsraten
unter zwei prozent für die eurozone
gelten als rechtfertigung für ihre
expansive geldpolitik was aber wenn in
wirklichkeit die preissteigerungen viel
höher wären
längst kommen wissenschaftler wie die an
der uni hohenheim zu ganz anderen
ergebnissen und stellen unverhohlen die
frage müssten dann nicht bald auch
wieder die zinsen steigen
frank bethmann vielen dank zum fußball
in der zweiten bundesliga steht arminia
bielefeld jetzt als erster aufsteiger
fest dem aktuellen tabellen
spitzenreiter ist die rückkehr in die
erste bundesliga nicht mehr zu nehmen
nachdem der tabellenzweite der hamburger
sv heute gegen osnabrück nicht über ein
1 1 unentschieden hinaus gekommen ist
und in der ersten bundesliga wurde heute
auch gespielt an diesen 32 spieltag
hatte borussia mönchengladbach den vfl
wolfsburg zu gast gladbacher drei zu
null gewonnen runter damit zumindest für
den moment tabellenplatz vier
du bist was du isst ist ja ein uralter
spruch ein bisschen ausgeleiert und
vielleicht auch nicht immer ganz
treffend aber ein stückchen wahrheit
steckt natürlich schon drin ja meist bei
kalender sprüchen auf jeden fall ist es
ein thema was jeden in irgendeiner form
beschäftigt manche mehr manche weniger
das hygiene-museum in dresden geht nun
in einer neuen ausstellung der frage
nach wie werden wir in zukunft essen
welche visionen gibt es angesichts von
klimawandel artenschutz und
ressourcenknappheit spannendes thema dem
stefan kech nachgegangen ist
jörg teubner ist hotelier koch und
philosoph der görlitzer findet es
unerträglich dass weltweit so viel essen
weggeworfen wird das sei respektlos
gegenüber den produzenten
mir persönlich ist es aber wichtiger die
produzenten vor ort kennenzulernen
deren philosophie ethik zu verstehen
warum die eigentlich in so eine region
noch produzieren uns wie sie produzieren
daumen dass idee diese gärtner bauen nur
an was seine küche auch verbraucht etwas
wegwerfen muss also keine angebauten
biologischen kreisläufen ohne pestizide
ohne künstlichen dünger es gibt niemals
um die einzige lösung
es geht darum puzzlestücke zu finden die
insgesamt eine ernährungswirtschaft
umstellen können damit hat er es in die
ausstellung future food im dresdner
hygienemuseum geschafft die sammelt
ideen wie wir ernährung künftig sichern
können ohne uns zu vergiften
ohne unsere umwelt zu zerstören future
fund machte aber auch klar dass
richtigen konzepte zur falschen zeit gar
nichts bringen siehe die fleischlose
adenauer wurst der hatte der spätere
bundeskanzler im ersten weltkrieg gegen
den hunger entwickelt doch die leute
kauften schon wieder echtes fleisch und
das tun sie bis heute allerdings nicht
mehr lange meinen ernährungsforscher
davon aus dass wir langfristig
angetrieben durch klimawandel und
nachhaltigkeit lernen sozusagen die
collagen potenzial der pflanzlichen
lebensmittel vielfalt zu entdecken und
das ist geplant base geht also das
fleisch wuchs als leitsubstanz
zurücktritt und vielleicht das einzig
wahre konzept gibt es auch hier nicht
klar scheint nur die macht ist mit uns
verbrauchern das sieht man auch zum
beispiel darin wie sich die
produktpaletten der discounter verändert
haben hin zu mehr bio produkten und zum
teil könnte man sagen dass wir als
konsumenten und konsumentinnen darin
mehr macht haben als die politik
eine position die wir nur mangelhaft
ausfüllen leider geschehen beim
einkaufen er dies mit uns sie montieren
sozusagen
zwar wissen wir um unfairen handel um
hunger und überfluss und doch schrecken
wir nicht zurück vor einem
offensichtlich sinn befreiten lifestyle
umgang mit essen das große fressen für
internet klicks und andere absurditäten
stehen krass gegen 80 millionen
hungernde menschen future food drängt
zur selbstbefragung was ist mir wichtig
wie und was will ich essen den
zeigefinger wollen sie eigentlich nicht
geben und doch hört man die stille
mahnung denkt gut nach und lasst euch
damit keine zeit mit essen und solchen
fragen nämlich zu dem was wir essen
man geht es jetzt auch weiter es folgt
nämlich hannes jaenickes neue
dokumentation im einsatz für den lachs
ein augenöffner mit erkenntnissen die
für lachs liebhaber nicht leicht
verdaulich sein werden und um 0.15 gibt
es dann heute plus mit hanna zimmermann
und uns beide geht es morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren es hat ja
in den vergangenen tagen viel geregnet
und die eine oder der andere faktisch
schon reicht das jetzt nicht mal langsam
tatsächlich gibt es einige regionen in
deutschland in denen es schon deutlich
mehr gefallen als in einem ganzen monat
juni im vieljährigen klimatologischen
mittel der jahre 1981 bis 2010 zu
erwarten gewesen wäre
in einigen regionen fehlt allerdings
noch viel regen aber da kommt schon noch
das liegt am zwei tiefs über europa die
drehen sich ziemlich an ort und stelle
bringen deswegen auch regen an ort und
stelle aber ein bisschen bewegung kommt
in den nächsten tagen dann doch die
tiefs bringen aber auch eine kuriose
temperaturverteilung denn morgen liegen
die höchstwerte hier in südfinnland bei
30 grad und damit genauso hoch wie in
südspanien oder auch am westlichen
mittelmeer sehr üblich für mitte juni
sind dagegen unsere nachttemperaturen
sinken auf 15 grad in der lausitz und
bis 9 grad an den alpen aber der nacht
fällt kaum noch regen in der feuchten
luft bildet sich hier und da aber auch
etwas nebel im nordosten ist es klar
morgen vormittag strahlt die sonne sonst
gibt es mehr wolken schon die ersten
regenschauer und gewitter und die weiten
sich dann am nachmittag aus das können
durchaus auch unwetter werden also
gewitter die mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen verbunden sind
diese gewitter bringen dann deutlich
kühlere luft das sind nur 17 bis 24 grad
im nordosten wird es sommerlich warm mit
25 bis 28 grad und das regen und
gewitter waren zieht weiter nach norden
schönen abend noch